now google is the dominant search engine
of the web
customers turn to google when they want
to find information about products and
services
that means people are actively seeking
information
to show your ads to active searchers or
people looking for your products and
services
you can use google ads which is google's
advertising program
in this lesson you'll learn how google
ads connects
your business with customers so you can
reach your marketing goals
now by the end of this lesson you'll be
able to understand
how google ads works discuss the various
targeting methods
and know the primary benefits of using
google ads
that lets you connect your business with
prospective customers
so for instance let's say someone has a
broken pipe in their house
and they want to find a local plumber
they often turn
to google to search for their answers if
you're buying a new house
you might search for real estate or
mortgages or moving companies all of
these are searches
that someone conducts every day so to
reach these searchers
you can use google ads now google ads is
a
complex system made up of multiple
networks
targeting options ad formats budget
management and so forth
so we need to take a look at how the
system works
to ensure you're targeting the users who
can turn
into customers now it starts with
picking
targeting methods this could be a user
searching for a keyword in a specific
geography
on a specific device and operating
systems so we'll get more into targeting
methods
as we go through our lessons so you can
write effective ads for those targeting
methods
you set a bid for how much you're
willing to pay
if someone clicks on your ad now when
someone does a search
and it matches your targeting method
then your ad can be displayed
so if the user looks your ad and says
yep that's what i'm looking for
and the user clicks on the ad they go to
your site
now at that moment is when you pay for
the click
or for any action that can happen from
an ad directly
such as calling your company now once
users click in your ads
they go to your site if they take an
action such as
calling your company or buying a product
or filling out a form
or just watching a video then you can
measure those actions
now this lets you see your data for each
targeting method
keyword and add data to understand how
each is performing
now we'll define this information as we
go through our lessons
so you know what to look for to make
data-driven decisions
then from those data-driven decisions
you can refine your targeting methods
test different ads and set appropriate
bids
based upon how each click or interaction
is worth to your business
let's say that you're a plumbing company
and you're only in houston texas
so you could target only houston texas
with keywords such as broken pipes
remodeling kitchen and other services
that you conduct
then for each of those keywords you
write an ad
and set a bid if someone is searching
from within houston
for kitchen remodeling they could see
your ad
so if they were searching from austin or
california or seattle
and they're not in your targeting method
they can't
see your ad so it's important to think
about
where are your customers how are they
searching
and then make sure your ads are
compelling and then you can turn those
searchers into your next customers
now the first network is known as search
this is when someone inputs a keyword or
a search query
into a search engine and then sees
results
there's more than 167 billion searches a
month
now then there's another network that
google also supports
known as the display network these are
non-search places that can show ads
so google display network is made up of
more than three
million websites and apps that encompass
more than one
trillion impressions a month now these
ad placements could be apps on your
phone or a newspaper publisher site
with so many possible ad displays your
targeting
methods help narrow down when your ad is
displayed
so you can ensure only those who you
want to see your ad
will see your ad the three
primary targeting methods to think about
initially
are location time of day or day of the
week and device
the location is where our ads are going
to be displayed
this could be every country in the world
it could be a single state
it could be 10 states it could be a
radius
around your business or your pin code
you have a lot of control and options
over location targeting next we have
time of day
and this could be time of day or even
just day of the week so let's say you
have a
call center that's only open from nine
to five
monday to friday then you could run your
ads only during those times
nine to five monday to friday now most
companies run their ads
all the time but you can't adjust when
they do run there are other
considerations
such as you're a small business where
you really only answer your phone from
eight to four
so you could only run your ads during
that time now if you're a restaurant
you might want to run your ads later in
the evening to take reservations
you can also choose the device and
operating systems where you want your
ads to run
such as mobile devices tablets computers
or all three
so for example if you're a pizza
delivery place most pizza orders are now
on mobile devices
so while you may be on all devices
mobile is your primary one
then you pick your location based upon
your delivery
area and then finally you choose the
time of day for when your business is
open
and actively delivering pizzas now if
you're a large sas
company and you're international your
locations
might be worldwide so we want to think
about breaking down our ads and keywords
by languages or regions so we'll get
more into how these breakdowns occur in
the account
our location could be worldwide our time
of day is 24
7 and our devices are just all devices
so you have a lot of control of your
targeting methods and how people can see
your ads
both when and where
keyword is an object you put into
your google ads account now a search
term
or search query is what a user types
into a search engine to see results
so when this search term matches your
keyword
then your ad can be displayed so if
you're a modeling company
and you do kitchens and bathrooms and
room additions but maybe you don't do
basements
you could pick kitchen remodeling
keywords and bathroom modeling keywords
but ignore basement keywords because you
don't do that type of remodeling work
now you can also choose demographics
such as age
gender and income level if you're a
high-end
art dealer you might only sell to the
top 30 percent of income levels
if you're selling female-only clothing
then you could target just
females now in addition we can do things
like behavioral targeting
which is based upon how people use our
websites
this is sometimes known as remarketing
if someone came to your site and they
added items to a shopping cart
but they didn't check out we know
they're almost ready to buy
therefore you could target those users
differently than someone who's never
been to your website
let's say a user searches for accounting
services
on google in maryland in the u.s
any time during the week they could see
an ad for a local maryland accountant
let's say you're on a call center for
mortgage leads and you're only open on
the weekdays
then you can run your ad for the entire
country only during monday to friday
during the hours your call center is
open and only show an ad
if someone searches for mortgage rates
mortgage quotes and so forth
so as we think about our targeting it's
where our customers are
located what they are looking for
the devices they are on and the types of
people we want to serve ads to
now google ads is an auction based
system
you set a bid based upon what you
believe a click is worth to you
and then google looks at your bid in the
relevancy of your ads
and they do this for all the other
advertisers as well then they
order the ads and the search results
were across display properties
based upon both the bid and the
relevancy
now this is an important consideration
as useful ads
are as important as your bids in
determining position
so we'll get into this later when we
look at organization
now it's not just who bids the most that
will get you into position one
is your ad relevant to the user
there's a lot of ways to make things
relevant and we'll walk through this
later
if a user sees your ad you don't pay
anything
only if a user clicks on your ad
do you pay the search engine that's why
it's called pay
per click advertising because you only
pay when someone clicks on the ad
now you can then measure results such as
acquired customers return on ad spend
revenue and so forth
now based upon the results you're
receiving from google ads
you can then refine your ads or change
your bids
based upon what those clicks are worth
to you
when we think about the google ads
benefits we often call them
the three r's reach relevance
roi now from a reach standpoint google
search
and the display networks have tremendous
reach they can help you reach your
target
audience because your target audience is
probably using google whether it's on
search or display or both
so the advertising system has the reach
that
encompasses your potential customers the
next
think about relevance this is a big
thing in advertising
are you relevant to the users
searches are often resistant to ads
that's why if you're watching tv and a
commercial appears
you might hit the fast forward button or
switch the channel when the ad
is relevant users like ads
they'll interact with them if they're
useful and
they're relevant so you can target users
based upon
many criteria which means your ad should
be relevant to users especially on
search when you pick keywords that
represent
your business as someone is actively
searching for that word
that means they're looking for a
solution so when users see relevant ads
they're more likely to click and do
business with your company
now finally we have roi known as return
on investment
as our third benefit return ad spend row
os or roi
let us know how profitable a channel
is now as you can measure results from
your ad spend
you can make data driven decisions based
upon how users
interact with your ads and how they're
becoming customers
so google ads has the reach that
encompasses your users
when you make good accounts and you have
good account structure
which we'll get into later videos you
can ensure your ad is
relevant to users so they'll click on
the ads
and come to your website so you can turn
them into customers
now with analytics and conversion
tracking you can see
exactly how much that person's worth to
you
so then you can adjust your reach and
your relevance data
to ensure that your return on investment
is fantastic from using
google ads as a marketing channel so
google ads accounts have multiple
levels of structure in order for you to
be able to control how users can
view interact with your ads along with
your budget and bid controls
now in this lesson we'll examine each
level of hierarchy
so you can understand how average
accounts fit together
and how data flows throughout your
accounts so by the end of this lesson
you're able to understand account level
settings
understand campaign targeting options
and discuss the purpose of an ad group
so when we look at the overall account
hierarchy it starts
where we have an account then an account
can be made
of one or more campaigns then each
campaign
can have one or more ad groups and then
finally
ad groups are a collection of ads and
keywords so as we look at accounts
campaigns and ad groups
each level has different items you set
with it
so we're going to look individually at
each of these items
to see how you can use various settings
at each level
now at the account level we have several
options that we can set
the first is account access this is who
can log in and access your data
so when you open an account you'll use a
google account
the list doesn't have to be a gmail
address you can make your own email
address for your company
a google account and then use that for
login purposes
but then you can give others access to
your account as well
from a security standpoint it's useful
just to have one
administrator who gives access levels to
other individuals
that way if someone leaves your company
or no longer needs access to your data
you can disable just that access point
instead of using
shared account logins now you'll also
choose your time zone
now some items such as time zone and
currency cannot be
changed once you open the account so you
pick your time zone
and when you think about it you it's
useful to have your analytics
your server and your marketing such as
your google ads account
on the same time zone now because if
you've got an
ads account in pacific time and your
servers on
eastern time there's a three hour period
of time a day when your data doesn't
agree with each other
so it's useful to sync servers google
ads account
analytics so forth into a single time
zone now you'll also choose your
currency
do you want to be billed in euros or
dollars or pounds or canadian dollars
and so forth
again currency can't be changed once
you've set up your account as well
and then you have billing how are you
going to pay for the clicks that you
accrue
and then you can connect other accounts
to your google ads account
such as google analytics google merchant
center firebase etc
so if you're using multiple systems you
can connect them
all together at the account level so
they can all use the same data
and then you have notification settings
how do you want to be notified of
suggestions or disapproved ads and so
forth
in some preferences like display
language
number formats etc so that when you open
an account
the two most important options really to
think about though are time zone and
currency
they can't be changed you can change
your billing later on or you can change
his account access and preferences but
time zone and currency
are set once your account is open let's
look at the campaign settings
you have an account an account can be
made up of one
or more campaigns so a campaign setting
is where you're going to tell google ads
how to
show the ads and keywords within that
campaign
so first we have the network do you want
to be on search network display network
or potentially both
and when you're first starting search is
the best place to start because users
are
actively looking for solutions
so you could have one campaign that
searched and another campaign that is
displayed
now we choose our devices at the
campaign level as well so it might be on
all devices we could be on just mobile
devices or just computers or just
tablets
if we want to run our ads at certain
times of day
or day of the week we also set those and
the campaign
settings so if you only want your ads to
run monday to friday
you can choose those options at the
campaign level
now is say you want your brand terms to
run all of the time
and then you have other keywords you
only want to run monday to friday
then you can use two campaigns campaigns
can have different settings from each
other
so you could have one campaign for your
legion keywords that runs monday to
friday
clicks go to a call center you can maybe
have
another campaign that's brand terms that
runs
all seven days of the week and they're
in another campaign
so that way you can segment out which
items run when
now locations are also set up at the
campaign setting
so if you're a multi-location business
you've got one location in houston
another in seattle
another in new york and you only want to
run ads in those geographies
you could either put one campaign
together and target
all through those locations single
campaign now all those locations
would use the same ads and keywords or
you can make a campaign for each
location
if you make a campaign by location then
any other settings such as time of day
or budgets
which use campaign settings can be
customized for each location
your bid method is also a campaign
setting
so with bid methods at a high level
there's two
types one's manual where you set the bid
yourself
and another is automated where you're
setting a goal for the system
and the system is bidding on your behalf
and then you have budget
how much you're willing to spend on a
daily basis so if you have
one location and you want to spend 100 a
day
and then you have another location where
you want to spend
500 a day that would be two different
campaigns
so you can have different budgets for
each of the campaigns
so when you want a campaign level
setting to be
different for some reason a set of
keywords location or something else
that's one of the reasons to make a
different campaign
so if you want certain ads to run only
in certain locations
only certain times a day if you have
budgets by product line
you use different campaigns to control
those items
so when you think about budget
management if you want a different
budget by product line you make each
product line its own campaign
so when we think about search here's a
couple examples of how we might set up
campaigns
might have one campaign it's on search
it's not all devices
it's only set to the country of say the
united states
it uses an automated bid system that can
spend a hundred dollars a day
you might have another campaign it's on
search it's only on desktops
it's set to france it's based on manual
bidding
it has a 50 a day budget so when you
want these campaign
level settings to be different that's
one of the main reasons to create
a new campaign for the ads and keywords
that are inside of that campaign now ad
groups are a collection
of keywords and ads and only an ad from
that
ad group that contains the same keyword
that matched to a search query
right can be displayed so ad groups
should be
closely related collections of keywords
and ads
so we think about the work involved and
setting up a google ads account
it's really quick just to make an
account it can be very quick to make a
campaign
but where you're going to slow down and
spend your time
is thinking about your ad groups someone
did a search they are looking for
something
they're going to then see an ad so that
ad is going to take them to a page of
your website
so you want that user experience be very
cohesive
so you may have one campaign the
campaign could have
20 or 50 or a thousand aggregates in it
right for each type of idea that you're
advertising
so if you want to show a user a
different
ad based upon their search term changing
you want a different ad group let's say
we sell shoes
now we sell hiking boots we sell running
shoes we sell dress shoes
now we don't want to do is put all of
those in one
ad group because if someone searches for
hiking boots versus
a running shoe versus a dress shoe
you want a different ad there's not a
good ad that explains
all those concepts so we could write an
ad
shoes for sale right but choose for sale
doesn't really speak to the user
if someone's doing a search for hiking
boots
right and they see an end that says
shoes for sale and another ad that says
hiking boots for sale right walk on the
trails
comfortably right they're gonna look at
the one
that says shoes for sale and say it's
not relevant to what i'm looking for
and the ad that mentioned the product
they search for hiking boots
would be relevant we get a lot more of
those clicks and conversions
so why we may take some keywords like
hiking boots
trail hiking boot hiking boots for sale
best hiking boots
and put them in an ad group together
right we make an
ad only for those keywords so we create
and add hiking boots for sale
walk the trails in comfort but then
someone searches for
running shoes that ad would not be a
good result for them
right hiking boots an ad that they're
looking for running shoes
so you'd want a different ad group for
running shoes
so you might have keywords running shoes
best running shoes shoes for running
marathon long distance running shoes
right and then we can make an ad that
says running shoes for sale
maximize your performance now if we were
really focused on running shoes and that
was our core
business then we wouldn't want to run
just a running shoe ad because that's
very general we want to get
more specific if someone's running a
marathon
they want long distance running shoes
others want
minimalistic running shoes you'll see
see people search for running shoes with
high arches
or better art support wide box shoes
so you can even get into those very
specific terms to create ads for them
in the ad groups when you think about ad
group structure
only the keywords and that ad group can
show for that
ad right if we have two ad groups
and someone searches for running shoes
right they can't see our
hiking boots ad because it's in a
different ad group they only see the
running shoes at so you can make
multiple ads in an ad group and do some
ad testing
to see which is best so if we look at an
ad group and we see here's another
keyword
that we really want to look at and the
ads we have
aren't great for that keyword we can
move it to a new
ad group so we may have one ad group set
stress shoes another for high heels
and we can make new adders for all of
these items
so that the ad and then where the user
goes on your website or
is specific to each of those types that
idea of keywords
so you might have many aggregates but
the trick about ad groups
is you have a core set of keywords in
each ad group
and then you have multiple ads in an ad
group and so as long as
all the ads and the keywords are
reflective of each other
then you've got a good ad group now if
an ad does not represent a
keyword that keyword should be in a
different ad aggregate
settings are inherited downwards across
the account
so for instance the account level you
set billing the billing methods used by
all the campaigns in the account
and all the ad groups so you set access
level by account so anyone with account
access level can see are your campaigns
in ad groups
so then at the campaign level we enter
settings like budgets location
so that goes from the campaign level is
inherited down to the ad groups
so any ad group in the campaign that can
show
to all the users in a location that's
set at the campaign level or budgets and
so forth
so then that goes from campaign is
inherited to the ad groups
so any aggro in the campaign can show
where it may
reach the campaign setting such as
location or it uses that same budget
where all the aggregate campaign use a
budget so if we have
different campaigns then only the ad
groups in that campaign
would use that campaign's budget and
that campaign's targeting
method so when you create a setting at
the account level
it's used at the campaign level and then
anything at the campaign level
is used at the ad group level so if you
create ad group level
settings for something you can set up
the ad group they're only used by the
ads and keywords
in that specific ad group ad group data
is
never inherited to another ad group
so setting hierarchy flows downwards
across the account from account to
campaign to ad group
and then the ads and keywords so the
first step to getting started with
google ads
is opening an account now once you open
an account
then you can fill in your billing
information add additional users
and connect your analytics account to
your google ads account
so in this lesson we will look at how to
create the initial account
now by the end of this lesson you'll be
able to open
a google ads account set permission
levels
and user access data and then connect
additional accounts
now before you begin creating a google
ads account
you'll need a google account to access
it
if you use gmail then you can use your
gmail
account if you want to use your business
email
then you can create an account and use
your business email address
you'll need to verify your account
through a text message code or through
an email to the email address
you're using to access your google ads
account now once you've established
how to access your google ads account
proceed to setting up your first
campaign
each person who can access your data
should have their own
login this lets you choose their
permission level
remove someone when they should no
longer have access
and see what changes were made in the
change history tool
which logs changes by user access
before adding a user you should consider
the permission
level that the user needs so for
instance
if you want someone to see information
but not change anything
you can give them read only access
if you want a user to be able to make
any changes
but not add or move other users they can
have standard access
by giving each user access you can
maintain control over your data
and also add and remove other users
as your need for accessing your data
changes
there are times when you will want your
google ads account
to connect with other applications so
they can share
data back and forth this is really
common with google analytics
by connecting google analytics and
google ads
you can see a lot of data in both places
in addition you can create conversions
or
audience lists in google analytics and
have them
imported into google ads if you're an
e-commerce company then you want to
create
a google merchant center account and
link it to your google ads account
so you can create shopping campaigns a
common problem you might come across
is that one email is the admin for one
account and another email is the admin
for your google ads account you might
need to give
someone permission to log into google
ads to connect accounts
or they might need to give you
permission to
access the accounts that you want to
link to google ads
so you have the necessary permission
levels in both places
to connect the data once you have the
necessary permissions in place
it's easy to connect other accounts to
your google ads account
using the linked accounts tool inside of
your google ads account
go to ads.google.com or just search for
google ads in google search engine
locate the google ads link and open it
then enter the necessary details such as
your email
and open a google ads account then try
add billing information
and select your time zones
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here